[Music]
thank you
hello
I'm gonna call back
how dare he
how [__] dare he
get it Royce
thank you for calling PayPal this is
James Martin how can I help you hi I
received an email from PayPal that I'm
being charged some sort of 899 Bitcoin
transfer that I did not authorize
what time are you there okay can you
please tell me the last six digit of a
trade ID number then I can help you uh
yeah sure it's n a five nine all right
sorry and as in Nancy
eight five nine
and eight five nine all right just give
me a moment let me check in my database
and I can help you okay no problem
uh thank you for being old are you still
there yes I am here
yes so now I can see in my database we
have received an order from your end
which is around 900 900 the product name
is a Bitcoin
okay and right now can you please tell
me do you do you have a PayPal account
yes I do have a PayPal account but I
haven't used it in a couple years
because I only use Birch gold as my
primary uh Focus
because of that we found various
suspicious activity on your account
that's the reason we are here to send
you a verification mail now I've been
hit before I I've been getting
discharged I've been hit before with
these before and uh someone got into my
computer and actually said that they
resolved it is is this related to that
sorry what did he said I have I have I
think I've been hacked before and I'm
just wondering if this is related to the
last time I was hacked someone actually
did tech support and got into my
computer and tried to fix it is this
related to that
it might be possible but let me show you
one more thing okay uh I'm Jewish is
that okay
all right because the last guy I spoke
to when I got hacked was being very
anti-semitic I just want to make sure
that this isn't the same situation I
just want this taken care of
yes sir right now I can see in my system
uh somebody tried to misuse your
information without the knowledge
without the permission and may the
purchase a bit Bitcoin through your
detail and the person name who made a
purchase this product his name is Mr
Jason Cooper oh Jason Cooper no I don't
know no unless it's a precious metal in
the last name I don't know who they are
again this will be the third time this
has happened to me this month is this
related am I am I being targeted by
hackers for running the daily wire I
just don't understand what's happening
like I'm getting honestly I know this is
not your fault I know you're trying to
help me but why does it why do I keep
getting hit with these hacks I I don't
understand I I have McAfee installed on
my computer I did not authorize that how
did this happen
all right no Rider without wasting of
any time we can simply secure your
connection right now through the PayPal
server all right and after that we can
send you a cancellation in refund form
on your computer you have to fill it out
the form and cancellation everything
okay perfect how do I take care all
right yeah so you need to do one thing
tell me are you in front of your
computer or laptop I'm in front of a
computer
okay so do I believe you have a Chrome
browser on your computer I have Safari
you have Safari yes okay now you need to
open up a safari okay give me one oh
come on give me give me one second
because I
hold on I'm sorry I was doing something
else on my computer just give me one
second open up Safari sorry I don't know
why this is I'm so sorry I had to hold
on I apologize it was what I was
watching I give me one sec
how does he do that okay all right uh
yeah it's open
no is that open yes okay so just have a
look in the very top do you see a long
story I'm so sorry yes yes hold on I I
I'm not good at computers give me a
second my Spotify keeps opening I
apologize
don't be hurry okay I'm sorry just give
me one second I'm panicking because I've
been hacked before it's give me one
second
[Music]
okay all right all right I closed
Spotify I had the control alt delete
okay yes I'm in the browser uh what do I
type
you can type over there he is a Peter um
L as a Larry hmm
f as a Frank
H as in Harry
e is an echo
L as a Larry um
B is a Peter
then put a dot like a period and then
cite yeah I actually last time I did
tech support they brought me over here
it's just the same site it auto filled
when I typed it
uh it's p l f h e l p dot s i t e
correct that's that's what they made me
use last year okay okay
now it's asking me for a service code
what's the service code
do you see the PayPal service over there
yeah it says PayPal it has it has the
hold on I'm sorry it has uh it has the
picture okay let me just tell you what I
see on my screen uh it's PayPal and it
it has it has the picture of a lady on
it or something smiling am I on the
right site
yes okay
you can put a service code over there
okay what's the service code
six eight I'm so sorry it opened again
I'm so sorry
[Music]
I'm sorry give me one second give me one
I don't know why this keeps opening ever
since they did this last time my
computer like the mouse moves by itself
I don't know what's happening I
apologize the last time I did this they
said they fixed it and now the mouse
moves by itself I don't know what that's
about I apologize okay service code
what's the service code
and once you start once your type of
service code you can see the arrow
pointing right inside just click on the
Arrow
it's not letting me click the arrow it's
it's it's basically just backing me out
of the arrow
uh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm gonna refresh
can you give me the code again please
a six eight three zero two
definitely
can you hear me no I'm sorry so the code
is six eight three
zero five I'm sorry what was it again
zero two I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
don't know why this keeps happening I
apologize
he hung up
that's funny
the highway in the gear was killing me
I don't taper you got some work though
Clipper taper [__] you kid Paul guy
thank you Betsy